what happens when you travel faster than
the speed of light you can't
you can't i'm paul sutter i'm an
astrophysicist and author and a host and
today i'm reading questions from twitter
this is astrophysics support
[Music]
at kiron seven six three three three
four one nine will someone please
explain
what is dark matter
dark matter a better name for dark
matter is invisible matter we've we've
noticed through countless observations
in astronomy that there simply isn't
enough stuff in the universe to account
for all the motions and dynamics and so
we think 80 to 90 percent of all the
matter in the universe is simply
invisible and and whoever said it had to
be visible yep that's our rules not
nature's
at keaton stone asks how many exoplanets
have been confirmed to date please astro
pals hey i'll be your astro pal today so
as of right now we have confirmed around
four to five thousand exoplanets with
more coming online every single day and
that sounds like a lot but we suspect
that there are around
a trillion exoplanets in the milky way
galaxy so and what we're hunting for is
an earth 2.0 we haven't found one yet
but we are finding all sorts of crazy
planets we're finding planets bigger
than jupiter smaller than mercury we're
finding planets the size of jupiter
orbiting right up against the face of
their stars where they're literally
getting their faces melted off that's
daryl 16519c question for
astrophysicists do galaxy spin clockwise
or counterclockwise yes
at wrath 69721-961
i just have one question thank you
why does a person in space age at a
different rate than to someone on the
earth so this has nothing to do with
space and everything to do with motion
and acceleration and gravity we've
learned through special relativity and
general relativity that different clocks
tick at different rates so the faster
you move in space the slower you move in
time the stronger gravity you have the
slower you move through time clocks
throughout the universe are all
asynchronous and out of sync with each
other
at nkb underscore sean
wonder what it's like inside a black
hole the inside of a black hole is
probably the weirdest place in the
universe outside of a black hole you can
go in any direction you want up or down
left right front or back but you must go
into your future you are forced to
travel into your own future inside of a
black hole you are forced to travel to
the singularity the point of infinite
density in the center no matter which
direction you look you will always head
towards the singularity and you will
reach it in a finite amount of time so
have fun in there at jesus
p1738
serious question
what is a parallel universe
there's two senses of parallel universe
that come into physics one is through
quantum mechanics where every possible
interaction can branch into multiple
different possibilities each
representing a different option for that
interaction
and another option where uh the early
universe underwent a period of rapid
expansion and then different universes
bubbled and nucleated off like like soap
bubbles in a foam we don't know if
either of them exist by the way at woman
bot how old is the universe these are
the things i ponder hey i ponder these
two
13.77 billion years old plus or minus
100 million years
at coffee ice cream can anyone explain
to me what are cosmic rays before i
throw these notes down a cliff cosmic
rays are high energy particles generated
in gigantic explosions throughout the
universe that are constantly soaking all
of space just don't leave the earth and
you'll be fine
at dr david what are the properties of
planetary systems and what can that tell
us about how they form and evolve we
have found
so many different kinds of planetary
systems in the galaxy but you can take
the craziest sci-fi author with the
craziest idea and it still comes up
short to what we actually observe in the
real galaxy with actual planets around
other stars take for example the
trappist system the trappist-1 system
these are seven
earth-like planets orbiting a red dwarf
star where three of them are in the
habitable zone of that star meaning
liquid water can potentially exist on
their surfaces so we've seen pretty much
every combination of planets out there
and stars out there we've seen planets
around binary stars around triple stars
we've seen planets around big stars
around little stars even dead stars
we're not quite sure what this tells us
about the story of planetary formation
because we're still gathering that data
we're still mining that treasure
at
swaggy shrek
simp what is astrophysics and why do i
want to do it astrophysics is the study
of all the stuff that happens in the
universe and it's awesome
at crypto glitter asks i wish i knew
more about astrophysics hey me too
like how do binary star systems even
work how does that happen space question
mark exclamation point repeated several
times in a row this is why i love
astrophysics and cosmology and astronomy
we're just talking about the weirdest
stuff in the universe here binary stars
are actually the most common kind of
stars in the galaxy because when you
form a star you've got a big cloud of
gas and dust and it collapses to form a
star we found multiple star systems all
over the place we were almost a binary
star system we didn't just form the sun
but that same cloud of gas and dust led
to the formation of the planets and so
if jupiter were 20 times bigger than it
is
it too would have been a star and life
on earth would have been impossible
at
seven sati
five five nine seven four when will the
universe end not soon enough i'm just
kidding it's probably gonna last forever
as far as we know it is going to
continue expanding forever eventually
every galaxy will be ripped away from
every other galaxy and all temperature
differences will diminish until we're
left with a cold empty
void
moving on that's louvie luv32
is it possible the gravity of our galaxy
and what makes up our galaxy is why the
speed of light from our location seems
to be constant but in other galaxies and
places in the universe where things are
different that the speed of light
constant is different this is a great
question because we are constantly
wondering if the constants of nature
really are constant and as far as we can
tell every single observation
measurement and theory has confirmed
that the speed of light really has been
constant seriously we've tested it from
observations from the very earliest
moments of the big bang itself the speed
of light is simply the speed of light
and if the speed of light did change
would totally mess up physics and make
make our lives a lot harder at gml music
a casual question for astrophysicists
hey
let's chat how many dimensions are there
four
we know that we live in a
four-dimensional universe three of space
one of time interwoven into a fabric
that we call space-time there might be
more big dimensions or small dimensions
but those are all speculative theories
at michelle floyd today's astrophysics
question does the spin of a galaxy
influence the spin of other nearby
galaxies it must it must not it doesn't
they're billions of light years away at
jhatman8 says what caused the big bang
it's hard to believe that a microscopic
particle started the big bang another
option i just thought of is a large
vacuum and a large pressure collided and
boom
we don't know what caused the big bang
we don't know what started the universe
our models of the universe take us to
the very earliest moments but without a
theory of quantum gravity we don't know
what started at all we don't even know
if that question even makes sense at
aggie self asks
what happens when you travel faster than
the speed of light you can
you can't travel
faster than the speed of light i'm sorry
you just can't you see
as you get faster and faster as you
approach the speed of light
you have more energy and in relativity
energy takes more work to accelerate so
you end up requiring an infinite amount
of energy in order to travel faster than
the speed of light and so it's just
forbidden when i watch a movie you know
they're in the spaceship and they they
press the button or press the lever and
they go faster than the speed of light i
don't care because when i'm watching a
movie i'm not grading homework here
folks i just want to sit back and relax
and enjoy the show
at xavier underscore html if the
universe is made up of mostly space and
it's expanding what's at the edge more
space the source wall something beyond
human comprehension at the edge of the
observable universe is just more
universe the universe is larger than
what we can observe because light can
only go so fast and the universe is only
so old
however we don't know how big the
universe really is it could be
infinitely big or it could just be very
very very large but no matter what the
universe doesn't have an edge it's not
expanding into anything it has no center
it has no edge i know it doesn't make
any sense but you know since when has
science ever made any sense
at powell ds astrophysics question if
you time traveled exactly 30 years into
the future you would not be where you
started but in space yes
yes
at equal opposite astrophysics question
is the quantity of dark matter in the
universe increasing decreasing or has it
remained the same since time equals zero
yeah the amount of stuff in the universe
normal matter dark matter boring matter
whatever it is has been the same the
density is dropping though because we
live in an expanding universe every day
our universe gets bigger and bigger and
so it's diluting out all that same
amount of matter
at schlei another astrophysics question
if the earth's axis wasn't tilted would
there be any way to directly observe the
passage of a year yeah good good point
here because it's through the axis of
the rotation of the earth that we get
our seasons and the transitions of the
seasons but even if we didn't have that
tilt we would still be able to notice
the passage of a year because of the
stars that we would see as we go around
the sun in our solar system we see
different sets of stars on our night sky
and it rotates continuously through the
ear so anyone who can observe the night
sky night after night over the course of
a year would be able to figure out
that we do have a year
at thin lens if you have a car that
travels faster than the speed of light
what happens when you turn on the
headlights first you can't travel faster
than light but no matter how fast you're
going the light always comes out of your
headlights at the speed of light because
that's what light does
here we have at yupili
hi there
hello i have an astrophysics question
and my question is
is the structure of the universe as it
stands at its current level of expansion
related to the original singularity that
resulted in the big bang
not quite
at the very largest scales we see
something called the cosmic web it's the
very largest pattern found in nature
it's literally made of galaxies but the
cosmic web had its origins but in the
earliest moments of the big bang where
quantum fluctuations in space-time
itself led to tiny little density
differences and then over the course of
billions of years these density
differences grew up to become clusters
of galaxies and in the great cosmic
voids at pw brewer question for
astrophysicists that's me how far from
earth could you detect a hiroshima
massage atomic blast with our technology
uh like yay far
we'd probably spot it on the other side
of the solar system but that's it
at rough shade whenever i read about
science i find i'm woefully out of depth
how can quasars produce radio waves and
why can't i listen to them radio waves
come from you take charged particles and
you wiggle them around and it generates
radio waves so quasars are spewing out
charged particles they make radio waves
and you can listen to them we detect
quasars with radio telescopes and radio
antenna
so you can you're just tuning into the
wrong station you need a quasar fm at
artem zinn astrophysics question into
the void should it be possible to blow
up a black hole from the inside no but
they naturally dissolve through hawking
radiation you just need to wait like 10
to 100 years and that's not 10 to 100
that's 10 to the 100th power
years so be patient
thank you for all these amazing
questions i hope you learned something
about astrophysics i hope i was able to
help and i hope you had as much fun as i
did